dernière réunion publique pour nadia et
comme à fontenay le fleury ce mercredi
14 juin beaucoup de monde pour venir
écouter celles que personne ne
connaissait il ya encore quelques
semaines lors de sa campagne elle a
privilégié le terrain et cette soirée
encore l'occasion d'aller à la rencontre
des électeurs pour se présenter et
rappelé son programme celui du président
macron celle qui est lui sera surtout
présentes à l'assemblée pour y voter les
lois ne souhaite pas pour autant se
couper de sa circonscription
j'ai donc décidé de créer une plateforme
collaborative et citoyenne et cette
plaie plateforme permet aux habitants de
la circonscription de se prononcer
donner leur avis des propositions ou
tout simplement exprimé des attentes sur
les priorités qui sont celles de la
circonscription qui sont au nombre de
cinq
et cela me donne l'occasion d'échanger
avec vous avec eux donc de d'obtenir
leur retour leur ressenti leur
composition des attentes et d'y répondre
de manière concrète elle est opposé à
jean michel fourgous pas de réunion
publique pour ces derniers jours de
campagne mais du tractage comme à la
gare de fontenay le fleury le candidat
sait que le siège sera difficile à
gagner alors il durcit ses attaques
contre son adversaire lui reprochant de
ne pas vouloir débattre avec lui et de
jouer sur le communautarisme élu local
il fustige ses probables nouveaux
députés inexpérimentés un député doit
faire les remontées terrain dire qu'il
connaît sa circonscription et qu'il ya
une loi qui arriva il doit l'amendé et
l'adapter aussi par rapport à sa
circonscription de dire ça marchera pas
chez nous pourquoi voilà c'est ça le
rôle d'un député c'est pas de vendre le
gouvernement il ya déjà un préfet a
cliqué le responsable local du du
gouvernement c'est pas un député il est
là pour faire l'équilibré
donc il faut absolument rééquilibrer
dans mon avis à l'assemblée nationale
parce que l'on est en engageant une dans
un dans un étouffement
de la démocratie et c'est toujours
dangereux lui met en avant son
expérience et rappelle ses résultats au
niveau local il espère encore un sursaut
des électeurs de droite qui
s'opposeraient à une trop forte vague
macron où tous ces électeurs des motivés
qui ne sont pas venus voter